what do you make of bob lazar's story in
terms of possession of aircraft do you
believe i don't believe in the bob lazar
story to be quite honest i mean
jeremy corbell has done a great job
interviewing him and
has done some you know beautiful
documentaries
um
i just don't i
i don't know how to interpret it
and um
you know and again there's some of the
people who
i fraternize with
think it's all rubbish
uh yeah but maybe he's right but i don't
know i mean
the problem is
and um
this is a little bit different about how
i approach the whole area than a lot of
others
i'm less interested in going over
old paperwork
and all these old histories of who said
what you know the whole he said she said
of the history of of ufos
i'm a scientist
i worked on the brain
area because it's something i can
collect data on i can go back to the
same individual collect their mri again
and redo it i can hand that mri to
somebody else they can analyze it i can
get materials i can analyze them i can
get some of these skeletons i won't
touch any skeletons ever again
but i can analyze it and somebody else
can reproduce the data yeah i mean
that's what i'm good at and so
you know i'm i i i'm not going to go
into the whole i'm not a historian
yeah that's true but there's a human
side to it
i want
sometimes i think with these because
again anomalous rare events
some of the data is inextricably
connected to humans
the observations right
um i mean i hope in the future
you know
that that sensory data
will not be polluted by human
subjectivity but
you know that's still that's still
powerful data even uh direct
observations like if you talk about
pilots
so it's an interesting question to me
whether bob azar is telling the truth
whether he believes he's telling the
truth too
and what also
what impact his story and stories like
his have on the willingness of
governments to be transparent
and so on so
you know you have to credit his story
for captivating the imagination of
people and that getting the conversation
going he's maintained his story for all
these years with little to no change
that i'm aware of so
um but there's so many other people who
are let's say experts in that story
um their gut you know you accumulate
a set of sort of uh circumstantial
evidence where your gut will say that
somebody is not telling the truth yeah
you